un vrai aussi vrai que celui des autres
écoutez je cherche quelqu'un qui est
prêt à s'installer à long terme bien
évidemment d'ailleurs je viendrai avec
ma famille faut qu'on aille habiter en
france ni dans un petit village au nord
de paris paul à paris
enfin c'est un peu plus au nord
bienvenue mais rigolo
à des noirs devant le bar à caen face du
conflit ici c'est la france profonde
bonjour 28 feux doux et les gens sont
habitués à voir ce qu'ils connaissent
boireau très bien c'est très bien pour
que vous me parlez comme inutile alors
bonne chance et bienvenus pendant que je
parvienne à gagner la confiance des
habitants ont toujours dit qu'il
faudrait c'est que vous passez du temps
avec eux je fais tout pour que les gens
d'ici ne s'acceptent paris m'appelle la
noire audoise iguane depuis touba magna
si ça n'avait pas tu auras aussi
seules les études pour mettre de devenir
quelqu'un surtout quand tu es noir
pourquoi c'est plus dur quand même
ça y est je sois longtemps dépassé en
mars
moi jamais misé un kopeck sur cela
meriem ans et plus de voitures
bordeaux entrait bien le peuple un
patent conduite waka docteur
moi mais qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
aussi vous n'avez jamais vu noir c'est
ça